winter is coming but before it does i
feel like making some lists
game of thrones fifth season coming up
fast but before it gets here
i want to have a little fun and you know
what top 10 lists
they can be a lot of fun so i've got a
few different ones that i want to do
i'm not going to do favorite seasons
because i mean we've got more to go i'm
not going to do favorite episodes i
am going to do some favorite characters
some favorite deaths and also worst
characters
we're going to start off with some
favorite characters and i actually had
to break this up into two lists so we're
going to start with the favorite
characters
currently living and if you've just
started watching the show aren't caught
up all the way through if there's a
great character that you think oh why
are they on that list i didn't mention
there's a good chance they're probably
dead so there's your spoiler warning
let's do this number 10
daenerys targaryen mother of dragons
breaker of chains
inconsistent character but when she's on
she's
awesome and she's been on a good
trajectory all the way through season
four so i think
we're really on a good path and honestly
if she keeps on the path she's on
she'll probably move upwards on this
list by the time the show's over
the reason she does rank solo has a lot
to do with
second and third seasons where she kind
of flopped back and forth
between being the strong leader and the
girl in over her head
i get that those are both aspects of her
character i just don't think that they
were balanced
juggled or switched between particularly
well when they were kind of battling it
out for
which side of her had better control
things are flowing much more smoothly
now
now that she's actually starting to
attain levels of power and realizing
how difficult it is to actually try and
rule
that's really interesting and i'll be
really interested to see if that kind of
takes the wind out of her sails a little
bit in wanting to conquer westeros
she's become more interesting more
dynamic and better balanced but
those few rough seasons that's why she's
not higher on the list
number nine brienne of tarth she's just
a great contrast to a lot of what's
going on in this world because
sort of the fundamental thing with
westeros and the game of thrones is that
this is
a dirty world with dirty unpure
manipulative scheming two-faced people
and she is the honorable knight bound by
oath bound by honor bound by duty and
that's just something that
feels like in a lot of ways it shouldn't
even belong in this world
but she is determined to hold on to her
integrity and her honor
and still exist in this world and that
is an interesting thing to see
now add to the fact that she's just a
flat out badass
and you've got a hell of a great
character number eight
peter baelish this is a guy i just
love to hate and that kind of really
started with his
betrayal of ned and just you start to
realize just how
dingy and scuzzy this guy is
and every time you think he's hit his
lowest depth he just digs a little
deeper
and what's really impressive about him
at this point is how
well his ambitions are paying off you
know what as time has gone on
you start to go oh my god he really has
a legitimate
shot at getting his butt on the throne
which is
crazy but really awesome and you
definitely don't want him there but
seeing him try and the lengths that
he'll go to is
he's just terrific villain material i am
going to call him a villain i mean this
is a world of
a lot of greys but he's pretty much the
blackest that any human character is i
mean the absolute evil is the white
walkers but short of that this guy
he's pretty clearly somebody you do not
want
taking power number seven davros the
onion knight
i've mentioned it before and a lot of
ways he sort of feels like a little bit
of the replacement of ned
stark because he is that more honorable
character and he
does find himself following the orders
in the commands of somebody who
he believes and has faith in but doesn't
think is necessarily doing the right
thing
and ned had been a fantastic character
so it's nice to get
that kind of dynamic in the show again
even though ned's dead
and as we get a little bit more of his
history and we see little bits of sort
of the pirate side to him with some of
his interaction with
other pirates who are still in that
business and just
really the amount of trust and faith
that he has
in stannis baratheom is really kind of
incredible
because even though he is very concerned
that stannis is going down the wrong
path he still has this
utter faith and trust that in the end he
will do the right thing and be the best
person to sit on the iron throne
and to see that level of devotion but at
the same time
not have it be blind devotion and he
has such faith in stannis but is still
willing to poke him and call him out on
stuff
that's a delicate balance and he handles
it
just fantastically number six elena
tyrell
you know in a lot of ways she did feel
like the only one who could go
toe-to-toe with tywin lannister
and just sitting down and just the
witticisms the barbs and the negotiation
now
ultimately he did kind of get one over
on her but she just has that presence
and that
same sort of thing that tywin has but i
don't want to say the light side of
to his darker side of it but she just
seems to be just slightly more toned
down with it
she's not holding the fact that she's
pulling so many strings over everybody's
head the way tywin is
yet she still has that same degree of
power number five
varys you know dynamic complicated
characters it really is the running
theme of this list and
varys is another terrific example he is
wonderfully complicated yet can be
summed up so perfectly in that moment
from the first
season when he's talking with ned stark
in the dungeon and ned stark asks him
who do you serve and he says the realm
someone has to
he has no ambition himself to ever sit
on the iron throne
and he has no individual loyalty to any
one person that he thinks
that person is absolutely who should be
there whether by birthright or whatever
he doesn't care
he's going to do the best that he can
that will enable the best outcome for as
many people as possible but he's got to
do it so behind the scenes and so
underhandedly because the guy's got
no legitimate power yet quite an
impressive bit of influence
it's funny because that first season he
almost felt a little bit like peter
baelish like oh we can't trust this guy
he seems sleazy
but you know at this point he instills a
sense of trust not from the other
characters but from the audience that
you can always trust that his intentions
are what he genuinely thinks
is going to be best and i'm going to be
really interested to see what happens to
him in the next season because
he appears to be abandoning the city
where he's got such strong roots in
where his entire infrastructure is
did he really give all that up for
tyrion i mean that's a huge step for him
as a character and i'm
really going to be excited to see what
happens with him in the future but
i think even more so than that moment
the turning point was when we saw
his enactment of revenge against the
person who mutilated him as a child
this guy plays the long game and people
as patient as him
they have a good tendency to come out on
top number four
brawn you know i said complicated
characters were the recurring theme of
this list
brawn not that complicated but so much
fun
i mean there's just something admirable
about a guy who
has more loyalty to himself and to money
than to you even if he likes you and who
will tell you that to your face yeah
i like you they're paying me better so
i'm gonna have to kill you now i mean he
doesn't feel like a backside where he
doesn't i mean he is a mercenary but he
doesn't have that mercenary field dude
he's just
he's too upfront he's too honest like it
is what it is what do you want
and his rapport with tyrion especially
has always been such a highlight for me
ever since the two of them met up
seriously i the show could just be the
two of them and i would love it just as
much as i do now
number three the faceless assassin i'm
gonna call him that because i would
butcher
the actual character's name if that even
is his real name i mean who the heck
knows
but this guy oh man so
few appearances i mean by far the person
with the fewest appearances to make this
list but he was
so intriguing immediately just this sort
of
oddness to his face into his line
delivery the way he interacted with arya
and then just what a freaking badass the
guy was
i mean this is the epitome of a
character who shows up
wows you and then leaves and you you're
dying to get him back he leaves you
wanting more i
there's a possibility now that we might
get him back remember i haven't read the
book so i don't know
but where things were set up with arya
where she's going at the end of the
fourth season maybe we'll get him back
and if we do
i really really hope we get this actor
playing him
and they don't go with whatever the new
face was that he put on in his last
appearance or something else
give us this guy back because his
performance was so good
and it was what made the character i
mean the character was cool anyway but
his performance really solidified it
number two
tyrion lannister i mean what can i say
there's a reason this guy has won
emmys for this role tyrion was an
awesome character
right off the bat just the way that he
owned his
stature and his standing in life and yet
he knew just how to pull this the amount
of power that he had
to keep himself going and get what
pleasure he could get and then later
just using it to negotiate his way out
of not getting killed
but we've actually seen him growing and
changing quite a bit
over these four seasons that we've
gotten so far i mean you think about
that lecherous little drunk
in a room full of horrors that we met in
the first episode to
where he was at the end of season four
going down that hallway with that
crossbow
i i don't care who you are i would not
have wanted to run into him in that
hallway
it could have been the mountain and i
still would have been like dude
you're in trouble tyrion is just at this
point feeding
off the resentment that the world seems
to have against him that he used to make
light up before now he's like
you know what to heck with you i'm
throwing it right back at you
and yet he still maintains that wit in
that charm i'm not gonna call it
lightness anymore because he's too
damaged to call it lightness but he's
still charming
even as he's grown tougher and harsher
it's just been a great journey so far
and i
can't wait to see where it goes so who
takes the top spot
over that little man number one arya
stark
you want to talk about a character who's
gone through a transformation i mean
she was a tough kid from the beginning
but where she is now
when she first had her first kills and
started getting that sort of
i don't want to call it a taste for
blood because it's not like she's a
serial killer but sort of realizing
not only is she okay with doing this but
she's good at it
to see her go on this journey now
knowing that she's headed to where the
assassin came from maybe she's
really gonna learn the ins and outs of
this and be able to truly enact some
revenge
not that it's ever gonna make her whole
i mean she much like tyrion
she's far too damaged to ever go back to
what she is but to watch her change and
to watch her become
tougher wiser and yet still
in some ways a child that moment
when the hound tries to take her to the
eerie and is told that her
elisa has died and she just
bursts out laughing that was possibly my
favorite moment of the entire show
it's like she's just come to realize
fate is a [ __ ] to hell with all of you
i'm gonna get mine for someone as young
as she is to be able to convey
everything that's going on it's just
astounding and there's not been a sour
beat or misstep with her
for the entire one of the show as far as
i'm concerned every move
that has been made with this character
has been right has felt right has moved
her forward on the path she's on and
it has been amazing and i love her more
every single time i see her so that's my
top list for the 10 best
still living as of the end of season 4
characters
on game of thrones what about you who is
your personal
currently alive character on this show
whoever it is drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned